hey there are hundreds of cologne out
there in the world some smell really
good and some not so much
so in this video we are going to look at
the sexiest cologne for men in 2018
specifically the five must dry
Cologne so let's get into the video
hey welcome to D LM model lifestyle I am
Daniel and if you're new to my channel
please subscribe and click the bell so
you won't miss anything
knock alone is not that cheap right so
when I give out my money to buy a big
bottle of cologne it's really got to be
worth it right well not really because
you don't have to buy the whole big
bottle you can just use sin burn now
what is sin bird well is this cool kind
of subscription based designer perfume
program that I stumbled upon that allows
me to try a 30 day supply of perfume or
cologne every month for only $14.95 I
can choose from around 450 different
scents from top designers like Dolce &
Gabbana
some for and a lot more just so you know
I added their link in the video
description down below so you can go and
check them out and do a little bit of
research now let's look at the 5 sexiest
must-try clothes now the first cologne
that we gonna look at is Versace euros
now this cologne is for a strong and
passionate guy and if you smell it yeah
Wow smells really strong but not in a
bad way in a very manly good way and the
main notes in this one are vanilla
tonka bean mint green apple lemon and
and Broxson the next one is Yuka boss
ice they call it ice because the
ingredients they use in this product is
from iced ingredients he's got a sexy
citrusy kind of smell with top notes of
ice men Bennifer and wild tea now the
smell
[Music]
smell is a nice uplifting kind of smell
that's not too overpowering at the same
time women love this the next one is
from Dolce & Gabbana the one for men now
this one is sweet and spicy goodness
this is classic and the top notes of
this one to Paco ginger amber grapefruit
cardamom and orange blossom it is
perfect for a date night next up is
Vince Camuto Tara this guy has an
amazing smell yes
it smells so good it's got this nice
kind of woody scent with a really soft
musk this guy will really turn heads and
it will last you for a long time
now the top notes are citrus is craniums
sandalwood rhubarb tonka beans and
vanilla the next one is from Dolce and
Gabanna light blue for at home this guy
let me just give it a smell oh goodness
he's got an interesting like sexy smell
it has this combination of bitter notes
and spice with sweet undertones now the
main notes in this cologne are
grapefruit bergamot pepper orange
rosemary and Brazilian rosewood this
cologne is light it is clean and it will
last you the whole day now I've added
the links of all these Cologne in the
video description down below just so
it's a bit easier for you guys to go and
check them they are my five must try
sexiest cologne for men in 2018 if you
liked the video give me a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in my next
video cheers guys
this one
Spray this one right in my eye
I forgot what to say it's not so good I
just zoned out for a minute all right so
if I did link up all these frogs oh man
coffee is so good gotta make a video
about coffee for sure hmm so good and it
is I gotta go to the restroom that is
what it is I got a I'll be back so good
so my favorite from these five can't
choose actually cannot I cannot not
choose which one is better
Donna the video is finished it is so hot
here you guys cannot imagine how hot it
is here I'm I'm up